Ronnie what's with the new glasses
they're very Hollywood it's a whole new
year new glasses okay yeah man he needs
help I mean the guy needs with his
clothes man there's always some kind of
issue with the shirts at least I got
hair look at you you're fine how old are
you you're always
look at that line it's in the Amelia
hey like Mike what do you think of
Ronnie's uh mustache in that yeah you
know what I saw a picture I saw him uh
we were watching something you look so
sharp with a with a with a with a you
know a buzz down like if you shave if
you just have a short beard you don't
need that big [ __ ] thing on your face
man I'm serious you look so much better
if you just shave it down it makes your
chin look really small too when you have
that he now has mutton chops on his
mustache that's where he put his mutton
chops yeah he looks good when he when
he's got it shaving down he's got a nice
shirt on
you know with the [ __ ] glasses who's
talking about these glasses what
happened there they look like protective
glasses well they look like racquetball
glasses yeah you know when you play
basketball play a game or something I
don't know but those glasses you know
they're very Vegas though they look like
you're waiting for like a nuclear test
at the desert
but I like it I like the story but
good story behind
them from where'd you put why'd you put
them on today
I got them last week so I wouldn't mean
I put them on today wait like how'd you
like what was the story you got them
where like where'd you get them and a
[ __ ] eyeglass place and what like you
saw those and what stuck out yeah did
you only try on one pair or do they only
try on a bunch of [ __ ] I liked them okay
[ __ ] yourself 900 other glasses that
would have looked so much better on you
than those yeah okay so what do you
suggest you're you know you're
considering
yeah yeah he's a big [ __ ] maybe just
a nice nice pair of Ray-Bans how uh uh
Ronnie something I had Ray-Bans for
[ __ ] 10 years those look good maybe a
pair of aviators might look good on you
I have aviators I still do he always
wears those like bifocals those like
they're not bifocals [ __ ] you could see
his eyes a little bit are those like
glasses and sunglasses no Ronnie you
gonna take Mike's advice and maybe shave
your mustache down no okay I got some
clothing uh recommendations for him too
like just stuff that he could wear like
in Vegas and stuff that you want to take
him shopping anyway just recommend some
things to him and yeah you know just
something that just you know just to
kind of give him a little bit of a
facelift you know like just something
that'll just face lift you know what I
mean like just you know face makeover
with the skull shirt dude I don't even
have a [ __ ] wrinkle what do I need a
facelift no I don't mean I don't mean
literally when he says facelift he means
he can't find a wrinkle on your face
you're covered in hair could Ronnie grow
the mustache all the way down to his
like his chest
and then he could braid it yes
laughs